the septic site within the street any
desperate situation it's very very tense
therefore it's a pretty big one all part
of it
I'm Stuart Ramsey in Hong Kong and I'm
Alex Beaufort in the Kowloon area of the
city and this is hot spots tonight we
bring you a special edition of hot spots
from the Smiths of Hong Kong where civil
unrest is challenging the Beijing back
up
where no idea what was about to happen
and my team meet the people behind the
protest and witness the impact of
escalating violence that night who
definitely felt like Hong Kong was birth
it started as a protest against an
extradition treaty between Hong Kong and
Mainland China after violent
demonstrations and arrests it's morphed
into a real debate about the
relationship between the two Hong Kong
has never seen anything like this tear
gas rubber bullets and street battles
well after hours of demonstration oh
I'll just broke loose that's never been
seen
tensions are running high
that just happened
[Music]
they're fighting for the future they see
which is not to be completely taken over
by China it all started over in
extradition
it was an extradition agreement between
Hong Kong and Mainland China
you have numbers of for 500,000 in the
next week and a million next weekend 1.7
million of people are still coming out
on the street many Hong Kong has felt
that the bill would really put them at
the mercy of China all the human rights
they enjoyed all of the legal rights
that they enjoyed the far better than
their own China there were a lot of
concerns about whether we may be seeing
another event that was reminding people
of Tiananmen Square
a large cross-section of Hong Kong
society supports the principles of what
the protest is what within that you have
the groups who are prepared to have
violent confrontation with the police
the predominant protest movement to
notice the black shirts these are the
guys who the most likely to cause
trouble they usually have FAC t-shirt
black bandanas and yellow helmets it was
kind of a uniform it became synonymous
with the whole of the movement
they've gone from these little white
masks you could get here from a building
depo to where a full-on mass with
full-on respirators everything there
fighters there guys who are going to be
on the front line we know that there's
large numbers of youngsters who are
already ready with gas masks so we could
expect some trouble
they wanted us to be at the front to
show the world what was going on
they all carry the umbrellas they're
really useful they use them to protect
themselves on rubber bullets or beanbag
rounds coming their way from the police
some of the big marches they go on for
mile after mile justice
initially it really was a straight-up
March confrontation to place a lots of
shouting etc the first phase of a
tactical change was direct confrontation
with the police then the police up their
tactics they change big
suddenly they went from direct
confrontation as soon as any groups
gathered together and that then pushed
the protesting groups in saying we
confront and disappear they call their
guerrilla tactics they go to an area
they attack it and then they use the to
beard away the testers don't want to get
caught by the police because they'd be
charged with rioting and that carries a
10-year prison sentence and that can
last in with the police when I'm not
continuously and all night
okay well after hours of demonstrations
the right places a decided enough is
enough and they're coming in now they're
firing a tear gas into the crowd try and
move them away from this police station
they just roll they coming down the
street
every time he escalated forward we get a
more balanced mass on the police I think
that's the only answer that the
government has right now and ultimately
the decision was they had to go much
further and it had to become more
violent so that they kept up the ante
and kept the pressure on the police
I was always with these cases as a black
chicken innate which one was the first
one to actually really up the ante
not seen so much tear gas deployed in
general in any protest very nasty tear
gas that they're firing so it really
hurts horrendous so we had have to have
our full face of the gas masks on you
couldn't really exist without it if he
wanted to be in part of what was going
on
disperse are we hired you have this
really interesting system which is the
raising of flags the hell this black
flag up and they announced what they
were gonna do you know when it's coming
you know they're gonna fight a tear gas
rally in ten seconds and you can get
yourself in a position to get the
different angles of shot
and then I stumbled across this homemade
slingshot
laughs ever see this is Scott for the
very first time and saying to Michael
what on earth this act basically there
was two guys holding these two
slingshots at the top and the one guy
was putting it back in the middle he
fired a brick deal and they were firing
it at the P station and they smashed
about 2030 windows they were always
surrounded by the umbrellas as they were
getting themselves ready smash their way
in the police are inside and five
minutes later they were moving on the
danger is not so much from the actual
either the police or the protesters is
just the fact that they're fighting one
another sometimes you sort of are there
because there is nowhere else to go
watch yourself watch yourselves they're
coming at them
like firing the pirate there's a nice
guy actually now as petrol bombs we
brought out with right between the
protesters and the police
their potential gain cursory closer now
to the police they've been firing this
over there also the chest is coming from
that side as well
they've got near a spirit can Anna
stones are coming here like all hell
just broke loose
by this day stupefied near to the police
there was books coming from all
directions we were hidden behind this
bush trying to kind of take shelter and
then he was completely engulfed in tear
gas and last day
[Music]
right behind us as well
the first thing we heard was an owl from
Stuart this break just come straight
through the hit but just smash do it in
the arm
you've got the mark Sonic's heart and
his tear gas we sort of got Keep Calm
there was so much going on at this point
I turned and somebody bumped into me and
my bag could just broke open okay
everything from my bag fell onto the
pavement in the middle of the tear gas
my passport you know my spare batteries
my bank I mean you name it just lying on
the floor so I scooped everything up
then as I turned just felt this but
against my upper leg and I knew had been
hit by something I wasn't sure what I
thought well it's either a rubber bullet
or a tear gas canister
evading
don't everything to get that seen to
so she's a little blood down here but he
said no I'm here and then actually
started filming straight away again I
was quite impressed by and then of
course we remember that the brick came
through the hedge and we later look back
at our footage and realized that is
exactly what happened I think we then do
a live shot in the street I don't know
it was simply overwhelmed by the numbers
he just starts bandaging me while I'm
doing my life I don't think the police
are stretched per se but I reckon they
underestimated this state's the police
have lost him completely lost the road
they were throwing it's never been seen
before it never happened before we had
gone to what was a reasonable-sized
rally that suddenly morphed into this
really significant rally because the
police had lost there have been a lot of
reports of police violence
[Music]
from what I saw in Hong Kong the police
were actually quite restrained in their
approach at least initially when they
are given the order to go in then it is
disciplined but they still have to run
around and people to get him clobbered
on the head the battles between the
police and the protesters did not just
go on on the streets one of the most
memorable moments of that captured on
cameras riot police just coming straight
through a metro station entrance chasing
after protesters pushing people down the
expected beating their heck out of them
panning them down on the ground really
violent scenes really violence seen a
lot more attention started being paid to
the degree of violence that was being
used against the protesters
versus their right to protest that was a
very specific tactic change the idea was
this was scared living daylights out of
kids and to stop them demonstrating he'd
manifested itself into a certain degree
by the takeover of the airport Hong Kong
International Airport is one of the most
important airports in the world it
became a prize worth going after because
if you want international community see
what's going on you're going to close
the airport bet this is all about
disruption and the protesters say that
over the next few days they're going to
stay in this arrivals hall the day
before they closed the airport there
after a number of days of demonstrations
to the plan by the process was to do it
again
airports are very sensitive places and
this is a difficult one Korea
[Applause]
we test the patience of those
authorities by being here
that morning when we arrived it felt
different the way they listed the game
was to go from the arrival sound and
just take hold they come up to the
departure section and of course it's
going to cause chaos frustrated
passengers trying to push through
[Music]
they did cause you can see gunfire's
tear gas even heating out that
protesters blood everywhere it's like a
war zone in Hong Kong at this stage the
airport was completely shut down
all passengers like to leave to terminal
buildings as soon as possible we had to
get my voice laid and I had to write my
track that the best way to do it was at
the check-in counter never written a
story at the checkout this check-in desk
I put my laptop set everything up ready
to edit heartbeat
one he's editing yeah here
and I can just see policemen arriving
yeah always slightly pull them over
Stewart and Dominic running back to me
and then they said it's gonna happen now
we had to get to where the police were
coming in because we have no idea what
was about to happen
what's happening the protesters pushed
the barricade and the police has come
back
I said Stuart you need to go live ma
inclination is usually to actually film
in worry about that later she just said
we're going live hello you're watching
the cable show straight to Hong Kong
Airport where as they say in the trade
it's all kicking off show at Ramses
therefore as Stuart what's going on that
was beginning a very an epoch few hours
without their riot gear to the police
are greeted with huge Wars from the
crowds inside and before you know it we
were live broadcasting and it just
unfolded from there that's when they
started piling on to the police wagon
[Applause]
that's it man
that's something they're arresting
people here as well
pepper spray is being used here
restraining them police themselves try
get back inside pepper spray was being
used and they were just scared so this
is the police
they're not messing around if I sit
erect coming to get their colleagues out
there are some moments that you cannot
capture in retrospect that doesn't
matter how brilliant your pictures might
be it can only really live in that
moment in which it's happening again and
going downstairs grabbing people taking
them out and put them into trucks
they're taking them away and in that
point of time we knew that what we were
broadcasting and what we were showing
the world was significant it was
something that they would sit down and
watch I couldn't hear
okay who's ever saying hey can you hear
me can you hear me these guys don't mess
around the whole story was unfolding and
developing in front of our eyes as we
were live in that moment you are as out
of the know as anybody else is and
certainly anybody watching honestly you
know I'm perplexed to be honest it is
we're actually I suppose experience
helps because you are not just saying oh
wow look at that you actually try to
explain to the audience as best you can
and as quickly as you can what you think
is happening I just assumed that they
would go
full clearance but maybe you can't
underestimate how difficult it is to
police just this number of people you
can be wrong you can be right and then
be wrong and you can be wrong and you
can be right and as long as you can keep
a flow of what's going on you could say
okay well I thought this was happening
but it looks different now ah I suspect
they're doing this you know where you've
got to think as you're talking to a
friend and just explaining as best they
can what's happening as we saw you know
throughout the course of two hours the
story just developed and developed and
developed snatch squad time it was it
felt like a little bit like a puzzle I
just had a quick look around because you
get two periods where you go you just
run out of things for a minute or you're
exhausted its initial operation I think
as far as I can tell
and that's why if you've got an
experienced presenter like Kay they'll
pick up and do a summary for the
audience
it's late into the night in Hong Kong
tensions are running high it's tricky to
say focus in those scenarios you know
you're thinking about multiple things
this is not
as Beijing is going to be absolutely
furious at this two days at this end up
being closed in this case has got right
please come in all sorts of different
directions some of the picture you can
see me to try to talk with my hands on
my in my ears because he's you know the
mall violence is pretty loud
[Applause]
everything that had pretty much
instructions it's a very chaotic
environment
and it was non-stop non-stop and I think
that was when I realized right you know
you're used to doing a big loud thing
coming out after 10 minutes 15 minutes
but that's a long time 20 minutes and
half an hour I realized wow this is just
not gonna stop can you see down here
there's people arriving people arriving
there you've just gone off your 12-hour
flight and you've got a riot in front of
your eyes you are in a zone and you are
just keeping going
Stuart if I can just interrupt you for a
second we've got images inside the
airport with a lot of demonstrators are
still there they believe that they have
detained an undercover police officer
the taking over of a two men for hours
at a time really shocked Hong Kong the
first Bylsma certainly Chinese policeman
and he was caught under cover and the
mob got hold them
[Applause]
police are gonna come and get him at
some point
at this Apple
the second guy was held for hours more
live on television again a man being
beaten they shout with press press press
and they moved out of the way and
creative like a football tunnel and they
let me go all the way to the front it
was fully a hundred people surrounding
this one guy and they started roughing
them up now
there's people pitching in others are
trying to help them doing
this is what happened
[Applause]
they pull out a t-shirt I got a lovely
Hong Kong police at one point he says I
love that Oakland Police so what have
beat me which they probably did one of
them was cable tied to an airport
trolley
it's not a good thing for them to have
done it's not clever because the fleet
of dots are the activist if they had had
any moral high ground before they
actually lost it then by beating these
two guys up badly
this guy could die to say he's been
pretty beaten up he's not in good shape
at all
he was laying on the ambulant bed in the
middle of the airport surrounded by
protesters pulling at his legs so this
is turning into very very nasty
their well-being at this man remember
Michael running off as they whisked him
away finally got him into an ambulance
[Applause]
most of the police had withdrawn in a
relatively chaotic manner some officers
got cool
one was left by himself and was
powerless they became this massive
insult because as they got overwhelmed
he pulled out his gun then he pointed
her directly at down
he thought he was about to die the crowd
immediately dispersed he did the right
thing that would have been a tipping
point for the entire protest movement if
someone had been shot and killed it was
just one of those moments where you the
enemy they would do that just happen
coming up the city goes up in flames and
violent clashes shocked Hong Kong
it was May I thought wow what's gonna
happen now because they have lost
control
[Music]
welcome back to a special edition of hot
spots from Hong Kong
well the scenes you just saw in Stuarts
report have gone from bad to worse my
team witnessed an upsurge in violence on
both sides all this at the heart of one
of the world's key financial hubs the
antipathy between the two sides was
increasing
it wasn't about just the extradition it
was about police brutality you always
think that the police are targeting you
but we knew for sure they were
why are you questioning him Alex just
wait straight in what are you doing he's
clearly marked as best people in the
office who are watching it live we're
saying oh my goodness which way is this
gonna go as each team went in things
were changing we deployed because there
is going to be a huge demonstration for
the anniversary of the umbrella movement
the umbrella movement had been quite
peaceful but it got nowhere
so people were showing up in force and
it was banned so we knew that there
would be trouble within a few hours of
that March which had been peaceful up
until that point we found ourselves
outside the Hong Kong government central
offices peaceful protesters scattered
they're protective masks within a very
short space of time they were firing
tear gas and that was the start
[Music]
these people are extremely determined
and they're not moving not moving an
inch they're these little discs about
this big and they move fast they're
metal and they burn Steph caught one in
the stomach another one bounced off and
it sort of essentially stuff to set fire
to Alex's she didn't even notice he
would craft down her this tiny barrier
one of those rounds comes at full speed
and hits the barrier right next to her
face the side of the bridge just stopped
it from coming straight in he's just
thinking God thank God it didn't hit her
in the head their own Skillman this six
hours just live just us running rather
streets Alex essentially me following
Alex as she charges into various
situations that explains in large
numbers of right police on the move
Toby try and squeeze your way through
that's what's happening they they are
struggling our local producer would be
across various chat rooms Facebook
constantly so wherever we were he'd be
on his phone information was going quick
and fast and the police always seemed to
be slightly behind the curve we followed
the protesters down and directions of
course wake Bay another area on Hong
Kong Island
and in the middle of this road junction
is a huge barricade made of metal
railings plastic I mean they pulled in
all sorts of things as I'm standing on
it I see that there starts a fire to it
so we jump off and it just went up
incredibly quickly still no police it
was mayhem I thought wow what's gonna
happen now because they have lost
control
this is Hong Kong this stuff just
doesn't happen there there's smoke
everywhere poxy finding pasty now you
really can't have each other because
there's a it's a roaring fire
[Music]
the heat is really meaningful sailors
are crackling on your skin another
temptation they have built a big fire
I'm not sure what
and then there's gas bottles in it they
start to go off as well and we're live
and she's maybe not realized quite how
close yet but a big gas bottle in that
would have blown bits of the barricade
to waters that could have been
incredibly being told to be careful
that statement
the police were just running around
desperately trying to shut down roads
and trying to push them back and stop
you know break down barricades and the
fire brigade was turning up and trying
to put out fires and it felt like they
weren't coping at all and that night it
definitely felt like Hong Kong was
burning
the police felt a little bit under
pressure and at that stage definitely
felt that the media was not giving them
a fair representation stick those
demonstrators holding coming down heavy
pulled to the side Alex saw a
photographer he has a riot cop ranking
he thought captain at some sort Markel
on his shoulder I remember he's really
laying into this guy they're checking
whether they are media and I felt he was
trying to intimidate this whole group by
picking on one guy who were all local
journalists think about what are you
doing
please this can also wear this with its
inaudible your name are you getting
control of the streets
I think Toby thought what the hell is
she doing and is this a good idea
okay fair amount of anger from the
police he just left in the end really
because I think he probably realized it
by this point we're surrounded by
cameras she's saying what everyone's
thinking
so he just pulls by her he hasn't done
anything though as far as I can say
didn't want to be filmed doing anything
questionable but even if there isn't a
crew there because everyone's got mobile
phones now the chances are that moment
is going to be captured by someone
the video that most people remember from
that day how these three kids which
you'd trade get batter here at least
and these guys were storming in smacking
their battens around beating the hell
out of what appeared to be civilians
there's a naivety to think you're gonna
get away with that in this modern age
there are phones everywhere so this is
the image that people remember all their
criticism of excessive force by the Hong
Kong police was there in these pictures
after the footage emerged of the police
storming the subway station and beating
people the mood sort of changed towards
them it was clear that it wasn't about
just the extradition bill it was about
police brutality
there was a very much of demin us
approached the so-called hardcore
protesters used to dress completely in
black covered their faces when they were
the ones who were prepared to carry out
some of the sometimes violent reactions
we wanted to find out what what
motivated these this hardcore group yeah
do you speak English people were trying
to cover up they didn't want to talk to
us if they were going to be identified
they're paranoid about facial
recognition and it turns out that in
Hong Kong as part of the 5g rolled out
there putting their 5g units inside
traffic lights there was this this fear
and suspicion of surveillance that
they're convinced that there's something
that was gonna be watching them so
they're smashing up and ripping down
every traffic light they go past we
managed to make a connection with some
of these hardcore protesters we went to
a lot of effort to try and shield their
identities because that was the bottom
line of the interview that they would
only talk if their identities could be
protected we had to do it somewhere that
couldn't be identified so we rented in
random air B&B sorry
I'm worried about your hair is there any
way we can put it up in the bundle so
they brought costumes really they
brought you know hats and scarves and
change the way they wore their hair and
you know had to take their earrings out
you know just nothing could be
identified because it's just it's it's
too risky for them to show the back of
their heads all the time if that gets
boring for people to watch so you're
trying to finish up more and more
creative ways of showing them so you
film someone's the reflection in a
mirror you know just a dead mouth
talking and but once they were
comfortable with that then they were
happy to tell you their stories we are
afraid honestly but when we went to the
street we all got prepare we all know
the Cossack wish but if you get
something like that wrong then the
repercussions for them could be bad and
they were good enough to let us in and
tell us their stories so it's our duty
to make sure that they don't get
identified like that really Hong Kong is
a place have many cams you can hide in
anywhere they had careers and
professions one was a policeman son and
yet they were all bound together
actually Hong Kong people hates
Havilland astronaut for the umbrella
revolution we apiece but as you know
peace is useless they just didn't fit
the profile of crazy mad anarchic
troublemaker they were very different to
what we expected how can these be the
same people who are out there throwing
Molotov cocktails at the police
[Applause]
we've got to remember that the police
felt very under siege they were
constantly having firearms thrown at
them even when they were plain clothed
or even off-duty the police were being
attacked and the war between the two
sides was just getting worse and worse
it's interesting to see people talking
about the police you know once the the
pride of the city trusted and revered
and suddenly they are the bad guys he
tracked down these wives of the riot
police all of them were incredibly
desperate felt very hounded it was like
a dirty secret that their partner or
their children's father was a policeman
we had been hearing about daxing which
is finding policeman's names and being
put online for everyone to see where
they live who their wives are where
their kids go to school so that they can
be targeted I don't have any Foskey mom
I only have one demand which is to keep
my my kiss safe in a safe environment
this is my leading mom you know just
because the husband is a police officer
just because they're out there on the
front line they suddenly find themselves
targets even if I choose to divorce my
husband
have you actually thought of that
yes
just solely because to put a my kiss not
because of I don't love my husband
but I love my kiss war I think we were
we were all so upset for her you know
upset for her and and the children it's
really heartbreaking listening to how
fearful they were you know cuz as a
mother you just want to protect your
kids you want to protect your family you
look at the situation and just sort of
everybody's a victim here
the antipathy between the two sides was
increasing it was boiling over into much
more than just discontent but you know
real bitterness real hatred real
resentment we go back for national table
70th anniversary of communist rule in
China the police and the authorities
knew that they have this big anniversary
in just a couple of days time and they
knew if they arrested a lot of these
people they wouldn't be around for the
day of this 70th anniversary I lived in
China for three years and then I was
based in Beijing trips to Hong Kong were
like a world away it was it did feel
like a completely different place to see
that the Hong Kong police in riot gear
was shocking enough let alone actually
charging and firing tear gas and using
water cannon marching down the street
banging their their riot shields and
pedaling us so that we couldn't go off
and see what was happening with the
protesters
it was apparent that we were now sort of
classed in with the protesters that we
were part of the problem
her mood had shifted again and there was
a very very definite tension
[Music]
didn't take long before the crowd seemed
to get bigger and we were in front and
can feel them pushing in and fall along
the police with them pushing us back and
literally just holding ever spray right
up in front of people's faces I think
Alex was trying to appease the camera
and straight away you get a jet you
don't even have to get a direct it
you are quickly overwhelmed by it
yeah they were trying to intimidate us
please were definitely trying to
intimidate us we heard a journalist had
been hit by a rubber bullet fired by the
police and it had hit her in the side of
the head she was basically blinded
sickening to see actually it could have
been any one of us all of a sudden
things you know just got real
rubber bullets can do a serious amount
of damage and can kill if they're not
used in the right way just seemed too
crazy really crazy
[Music]
the hardcore protesters were gathered
around the government building to smoke
coming
it was quite confrontational it was long
and we were alive
[Music]
riot police just swarmed out and just
started gathering out the protesters
we treated to Jennifer please started
pulling people out neutralizing them as
a threat it looks like a war zone
because there were bodies all over the
place being tended to by ambulance and
medics and a lot of them were
unconscious on having to have oxygen
administered and that day nearly 20% of
those that they arrested ended up in
hospital so that gives you an idea about
how severe the arrests were on the 70th
anniversary everyone's feelings were
very tense and they knew that the world
were watching this grand parade going on
in Beijing they wanted to embarrass
China and they wanted to make the world
notice really sit up and take notice
what was happening in Hong Kong
we found ourselves sort of in the same
position we had been on the first day of
our first trip we're up on the bridge
government buildings there's police out
front and it just turns very quickly
not coming put on your boss yeah I felt
a little bit exposed at that point we
want to go live because we're in the
thick of it
and calves you know I'm trying to phone
in but the gas masks on and talking to
master control and they're saying we're
not seeing you and kept saying but we're
up and old something holds up and of a
cable that had fallen out of the camera
then our security god I just hear him go
off
fall backwards and and we'll go my god
he's been hit the strap offence
backpacks are cushioned the blow but he
did go over and that didn't scare the
out of us you always think that the
police are targeting you but we knew for
sure because crouched down next to us
there were guys who had petrol buns
while we're out trying to escape a water
cannon coming down the street word comes
that a protester had been shot shot in
the chest and was bleeding quite heavily
oh wow and that's the guy that shot the
pictures that we got we saw the young
protester coming in and whacking the
policeman's arm
he'd already got his gun out within a
split second he had fired it directly
into the teenagers left shoulder
that is incredible virtually at
point-blank range I think that shocked
everybody
it was obviously a sobering moment for
everyone
these are mums and fathers and
schoolchildren all showing their disgust
and how the police have handled this
whole movement
on the 70th anniversary a rubican was
crossed and people started attacking the
police with even more ferocity even more
ferocity I think we felt like we were
there at a very significant moment and
it's gone on for far longer than anyone
expected such a gulf between the sides
it's really difficult to see how they're
going to sort that out anytime soon
[Music]
difficult to nowhere Hong Kong's gonna
go from here
but none of it looks good I don't know
how these protesters succeed to be
honest it just feels like sooner or
later someone's going to die
why I don't know how you can stop these
people being out on the streets and
demonstrating after this amount of time
can a genie be put back in the bottle on
our social
it seems to me it's adaptive it'll be
resolved
violently because China is duty-bound
are supposed to protect their own system
and has no intention of not intervening
at some point and making this stop
the Hong Kongers field time is running
out for them
China's got time to wait right now the
future looks very bleak
I find it kind of funny I find it kind
of sad the dreams in which I'm dying are
the best I've ever find it how to tell
you I find it hard to take when people
run in circles it's a very free
[Music]
you